do you have any New Year's resolutions
you want those people that says okay I'm
gonna try and use a few or I'm gonna do
this or do that you know how dare you
I think we all need to lose a few except
you looks fine the way you are I'm a
softer man no I'm Joey I feel so I like
that though I'm a thicker milkshake yeah
I'm not trying to change that I love
myself but uh there are a couple things
I'd like to improve in 2016 like this is
the year I would like to get to a level
of personal confidence where I can tell
a cab driver not to text while he's
driving oh I can't do it you don't have
the confidence to say please don't do
that
I haven't no it doesn't matter what is
he doing what are you calling an uber to
race what is he doing I just want to be
like could you please pretend like I'm
paying you American money to drive me
somewhere please I he's sort but I don't
I just want him to like me I'm like
you're interesting where do you pee like
I just terrible questions where do they
people where do they huh you got to do
something way way worse I realize for me
to speak up this happened to me recently
I was in New York City or on the West
Side Highway middle of the day cab
driver starts driving with his knees
so I perk up something is about to
happen because you know you need hands
and cure to drive yeah not optimal yeah
he was like know where we're going we
don't need hands and this is what so I
knew something was about to happen
something was afoot and I he went into
the passenger seat yeah a hands he went
into the passenger seat opened up a case
of some sort took out a flute did this
really happen
this happened took out a flute a flute a
two-handed wind instrument and not to
admire the flu like ah that's a fruit
and
it wasn't that I would have understood
that he took out the flute and started
playing the flute while driving that's
great that's that's crazy yeah that's
over my own line yeah I get it it's hard
to find practice time I understand but
wait till you hit a red light and bang
out some scales and keep them fingers
loose I understand that but I had to
lean forward in a car on earth filled
with air we were alive I had to lean
forward and say sir I can't believe I
have to say this but could you please
not play the flute
he's up there like doo doo doo doo just
why would driving don't play the flute
and this is what makes it a story to me
he acted like I was crazy because I got
mad at you he was mad it was a good
what's your problem like you know you
know even if you're alone if you're
driving alone whilst playing the flute
you're going like this is pretty messed
up what I'm doing right you know you're
doing something wrong I caught you I
caught you flute handed the give away
with the flute music I'm sitting in the
back like that sounds live yeah yeah
I swear to God I was in the Midwest
somewhere on a part of a tour and I was
in a van and I looked out the window I
think I was outside st. Louis and I saw
a car driving alongside of me and there
was a guy heavy fellow who was driving
with his knees and he had a turkey
dinner in his lap and he was eating it
with both hands it was an ax plate and
he had it on a briefcase and he was
eating a whole meal that Norman Rockwell
would paint I'd buy that painting yeah
yeah the modern Thanksgiving modern
Thanksgiving hey thanks for watching
please subscribe to my youtube channel
so they will stop making me shoot these
videos please